[Music]
hey everybody what's up it's
what day is it today's tuesday
that's right it's tuesday tuesday we're
doing dolls
1987 i think 87 yes it is
this is unusual because i had heard of
this movie but i don't remember if i did
see it it was probably like a long time
ago
because it was one of those ones it has
a great cover like in a great poster
yeah so it was one of those ones that
you always saw in the video store
but i didn't realize until shutter just
added it a couple weeks ago so i was
like oh we got to get around to like
watching that i didn't realize that
stuart gordon directed this [ __ ] yeah i
i don't even reanimate her fame i
definitely used to see this at the video
store but i didn't get it because of
that cover
i looked at yeah you know when i was
younger i was like oh that's going to
suck
i don't want to see a movie about i
don't want to see a horror movie about
dolls
you know i wanted to see [ __ ] like
aliens and [ __ ] like that you know
pretty much types of gotcha so i was
like nah i don't want to see something
about dolls but it's a good movie
it is actually it's weird because
this was actually even though it came
out after
from beyond it was actually shot before
from beyond yeah um but then came out
after because from beyond came out in
86. had i known it was the same director
i probably got it but i wasn't paying
attention to directors names that much
yeah when i was a kid i mean i don't
like i said i didn't even realize this
was stupid i feel like somebody maybe
told me that like a long time ago but
they'll like i forgot about it yeah but
then when shutter added it i was kind of
like oh maybe you should watch this
because i couldn't remember if i'd ever
seen it or not two of the two of the
characters in it are hot proto kind of
goth punk rock girls kind of like uh
kind of like rose
rose mcdowell from [ __ ] strawberry
switchblade they kind of look like that
although the one blonde one actually
just looks straight up like madonna in
the lucky star video yeah and then the
other one is actually the girl from the
take on no that's the same girl yeah
okay yeah the blonde girl is the girl
from the take on me video right yeah
bunty bailey yeah she's dressed kind of
like
madonna but they got the bubbles in
their hair like strawberry switchblade
and stuff yeah and like all the
necklaces necklaces and polka dots and
that kind of [ __ ] yeah
and they're mean
they're mean kind of criminal girls
trying to steal [ __ ] that's kind of like
what that's kind of like uh goes along
with all the 80s like all the punk
rockers and 80s movies were always kind
of like they're always heads yeah right
[ __ ] they're always criminals criminals
which is uh where you're always getting
[ __ ] thrown at us you know we would like
to substitute i guess
they couldn't they come they couldn't if
they couldn't show like black people or
hispanics in that light you had to be a
white person well what kind of white
person would use oh those [ __ ]
terrible punk rockers
with their silly hair yeah we were just
like another racial stereotype
yeah
[ __ ] funny but it was like because i
can't really think of that many movies
that came out in the 80s where the punks
weren't the bad guys no
i mean yeah they were [ __ ] so they
did that [ __ ] because it was safe
because they were all [ __ ] punk
rockers and goths they're making
working in hollywood at that time i'll
just i'll just wear my clothes
i need that outfit and i'll do that
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
you gotta make somebody look like [ __ ]
and they're definitely not gonna make
[ __ ] just
you know middle-class californian people
look like [ __ ] i guess not that era
yeah they did because i kind of well
yeah because like a lot of yuppies and
frat boys and stuff like that they were
always they were villains and yeah but
i'm just yeah it's like they weren't
middle class though those were the upper
class
yeah i kind of feel like they were
villains more often than punk rockers
but if punk rockers were in a movie in
the 80s you could almost be assured that
they were they were uh they were
substituting yeah they were substitute
for white trash
yeah i guess so even though most goths
and stuff were yeah pretty good they
show the white trash and [ __ ]
[ __ ] too and then rednecks
well like you know everybody's shown to
be absolutely in movies it's like i
don't feel like i don't know i just feel
like whenever you see punk rockers they
don't they never really get it right but
uh but yeah so that's kind of okay so
this movie well they know they never
knew no because it was just like you
know we just wanted somebody that like
looked like that in the movies yeah it's
like we had to make him a villain or
whatever so it's kind of like so this
movie like i said it's
i think that the mansion where they
shot this movie that's actually i don't
think that's like a real match i think
they built that like it's built a set
and it's in italy because i guess it was
cheaper to film there in the 80s
and even though it's supposed to be
england i'm pretty sure in the movie
even though i'm pr i don't even know if
they specify but they shot it in italy
and that's the same set that they used
for from beyond so you know that was
economical so it's like well we had to
build this whole mansion set but we got
two movies out of it so you know there
you go
i think this only cost like two million
dollars to make only two million dollars
i wish somebody gave me only two million
dollars but um but you know for a movie
that's like not very much but so the
thing about this is that even though
you know it's stuart gordon it came like
right and he made it like right in the
middle of like the reanimator from
beyond one two punch but this one is
kind of a lot different it has like
a similar tone to it i feel like it's
not as zany
this one is kind of more like
it ha definitely has a lot of comedic
elements
and it's almost i want to say it's
almost
kid-friendly except for a couple scenes
in there that are kind of like probably
you don't want a little kid watching it
but i feel like if a kid's like 10 or 11
it's probably fine i don't even think a
little kid nowadays it'd be fake well
probably not but i'm just talking about
back then yeah um because this is
because there's a couple of scenes in
there like with eyeballs popping out and
stuff like that but it's not like a big
gore fest like [ __ ] not realistic
either and it's yeah so it's kind of
like that type of thing but it's i feel
like it has like a weird like fairy tale
it's a fairy tale is essentially what it
is
so
you uh yeah pat hatfield said charles
bands had a castle in italy that's
probably why i was filmed there yeah
that's probably why this was yeah this
was actually
yeah it was well like i said that i'm
pretty sure this the set they shot this
on was a set i don't think it was a
house okay but um they might have shot
they might have shot castle freak at his
castle though now that i'm thinking
about it
but uh yeah because charles band
this was prior to because cindy have a
thing later called like full moon
pictures or whatever it was called that
does like culture they did i think they
did like transfers they did the puppet
master movies
i'm pretty sure they did transfers but
so he was kind of known for doing these
sort of low budget sort of schlocky like
b movie type things some of which that's
like d movie some of which were good
some of which were good but some of
which were you know it wasn't because
actually i quite liked uh at least the
first puppet master movie i don't see in
any other but but this one actually has
the same
has the same sort of premise as puppet
master kind of um but this predated
puppet master and also the guy that
plays the old
witch or the old warlock dude the toy
maker guy rolfe is the same dude that
played the toy maker guy in the puppet
master movies later on she's biting
metal stop biting metal
she's like why why not yeah she
why would you bite something metal i do
what i want she just i don't know she's
very into it for a while she was doing
it and i thought she was just like
teething or something like they say
about babies no she just likes it she
likes to chew on metal she likes to chew
a metal leg of a damn little she likes
to chew on metal and she likes to chew
on wood yeah
i got her some like little sticks and
stuff to chew on and she chews on those
but then she chews on she's sitting
there wagging her tail like a dog isn't
that funny no it's not fun
oh my god yeah but yeah so basically
what happens in this movie
is that you have
uh
this pair of parents it's like a dad and
a stepmom and like the stepmom is the
worst she's like the evil stepmother in
a fairy tale right uh fun fact that's
that was stuart gordon's wife
hillary uh not hillary mason that wasn't
her name um i can't remember what her
name was but uh hilary mason played the
old lady in the movie but um yeah so
that was stewart gordon's wife just
playing a [ __ ] on wheels
and they have this little girl named
judy
and they're on vacation it's supposed to
be like i said i think it's the english
countryside even though they shot in
italy so there's this horrible storm
the car gets stuck and they can't move
it and then they notice this mansion
like that's kind of off the thing so
like okay well let's run over there and
get out of the rain uh which was a very
rocky horror moment i kind of got that i
even started singing there's a light at
the frankenstein place like when i was
watching this movie but yeah so they go
in there they knock on the door and
nobody answers and so they just straight
up like break into the [ __ ] cellar as
one does
um so then like this old guy comes down
with a gun and it's like hey what the
[ __ ] you doing on my cellar and they're
like oh it was raining and nobody
answered so we just came we just thought
we'd bust in like like you do and now
yeah
actually just entering there's so
there's so much breaking it energy
but yeah so but the old guy is like
surprisingly chill with it he's like
okay we just made some soup why don't
you just come upstairs and yeah these
storms are the worst aren't they blah
blah so then it's like him and this is
the old lady i guess in england just
walking into somebody's house there's
not much risk you're getting blown away
here you'd get shot
well yeah that's what i mean yeah if i
walk in find somebody to give them
through my fridge i don't know you
you're not gonna make it out alive
well yeah it's like because what are you
doing because why won't you do it yeah
you're too stupid to be left alive
you might pass on your stupid jeans yeah
yeah somebody wanted to mention too that
uh that guy rolfe yes he was in mr
cerdon i guess which one of these days i
want to do a retrospective on that movie
too because i actually really dig that
movie but uh yeah he was in that when he
was younger but so so they have soup and
everything and then i forgot to mention
there's this really great scene like
while they're walking to the mansion
where the stepmom was her name rosemary
i think her name was rosemary and just
because she is a giant twan she just
dies um she takes away judy's teddy bear
for no reason um and just like throws it
into the forest like hey [ __ ] you kid um
so judy has this moment where
she has kind of like a daydream where
teddy gets really big and like turns
into a monster and then like tears her
stepmom's arms off and then like starts
eating her dad and stuff
and i guess they did that scene to like
establish one to have kind of like some
gory [ __ ] happening like right in the
first few minutes of the movie but like
stop trying to dig through the damn
books
and she looked at me she's just what
what i'm not doing i'm not trying i'm
just doing my pookie activities i do
pooky activities yeah ridiculous but
yeah so they're just trying to establish
you know they want some gore from the
outset but they also want to establish
that judy is like really imaginative and
her parents don't like that for some
reason because they hate love and joy uh
and they also don't want kids clearly so
i guess the dad has like married
rosemary because she's like a wealthy
heiress who wears a towel on her head
all the time like it was a dude actually
um no that's no like i said that's
stuart gordon's wife she just likes
shoes
that's stewart gordon is dead
sorry
yeah i thought it was a dude well
you know they did kind of like make her
they put like harsh makeup on her i
guess so she would look more like an
evil stepmother type
very square jaw square head well she
can't help that yeah okay you can't like
help with shape your [ __ ] jaw is
that's your bones
i'm still suspicious you're still still
very suspicious i don't know you you'd
have to ask her okay but uh but yeah so
there's that whole thing so
when the family like breaks into this
these nice old people's uh house
the old guy is basically oh i'm a toy
maker and you don't you know what
happened to where's your doll don't you
have a toy like to play with and she
doesn't she doesn't nark on her stepmom
because her stepmom's looking at her
like you better not tell him like that i
threw your [ __ ] teddy bear away
because i'm the worst she's like uh yeah
i just lost it whatever so the old guy
gives her this little doll that looks
he's like uh you know like punching judy
because he little mr punch and he's like
super super creepy
so then like they're all sitting there
eating and then somebody else [ __ ]
breaks in at this point it's ralph who's
kind of this like schlubby kind of
lovable uh you know child at heart type
of dude and he's picked up these two
punk rocker chicks
uh who are also [ __ ] actually i
think that when he picked them up
because it was raining they were
planning on robbing him but now that
they ended up at this house they're like
oh score now we're just gonna rob this
[ __ ] mansion because i'm sure there's
all these like doesn't like the the
the aha girl doesn't she um
she says antiques in a weird way like
antiques or
and
what's her name again her real name was
bunty bailey yeah bunty named like bunty
i do i do do hand it to her though she
could act
yeah she can act yeah she acted it was
she did a good job in the movie she's
cute too real cute
yeah i'm pretty sure that's her name
yeah but i checked that is that girl
from the take on me video from aha it is
yeah and like i watched another uh
review of this too and they also
appointed and she's much smaller than
she looks in that video she's tidy she's
maybe
4 10
4 10 and maybe about 80 pounds when you
say she was that small
i didn't remember her being particularly
small she was very small very and very
thin
okay she was yeah well she was like
really thin i didn't recognize i didn't
realize her being like look like a
little bitty dancer or something
but yeah so yeah so they bust into this
house too just like oh hey it was
raining so we just decided we were again
gonna break into your house
so the old people are like super nice to
them and it's like yeah this is probably
gonna storm all night so you guys can
just like chill here and they'll like
give they give them rooms and everything
but
what the people staying in the house
don't know is that the toy maker
i guess essentially what they're doing
is their witches right but they're not
the old people aren't really bad guys
though you know what i mean they're kind
of bad guys but this is kind of like a
story it's like i said it's a fairy tale
and it's like a morality story
because judy the little girl and ralph
who is the the nice guy
you know the kind of oh i'm a kid at
heart and he's like really into all the
toys and he thinks it's like really cool
and everything
they end up like okay but everybody else
who is a dick ends up uh
you know spoiler alert all the dolls
come to life and kill people
and what they're doing too is everybody
that gets killed in the house
it gets turned into a doll like they're
cursed to get turned into a doll it's a
doll formation
start transforming they transform into
it all which actually i kind of like
that one scene where the other punk
rocker girl
um not not the aha one yeah the little
brunette the little brunette one cute
too
she um at some point like the dolls
attack her and she like starts stepping
on them and stuff and then like when
their faces like when the ceramic breaks
away from their faces there's like
little like gooey like skull skeleton
type action in there which like i
thought was really cool actually the
special effects in this the way the
dolls move which it was all puppets and
stop motion
and for this being such a low budget
movie like the doll effects were
actually really really good i thought
everybody in this movie is familiar you
kind of recognize them from other movies
and
stuff you know in the united states and
europe i recognized pretty much
everybody even that other puck rock girl
looked familiar but i couldn't place her
i couldn't place any of them i didn't
really know any of their names
just the dude the overweight dude and
and bunty i recognized them
yeah but everybody else
everybody else is like real familiar so
this wasn't kind of an all-star cast i
guess in a way it just
i just couldn't really call the names
yeah because i knew like i recognized
him that old the lady that played the
the old lady like the the witch
she was in what the [ __ ] was she in she
looked like something you'd see in some
hammer horror movies no she was in
something in the 80s
that i remembered like you know looking
like an older lady but i can't remember
he looked real familiar too
well he was in a [ __ ] ton of stuff yeah
he was later because you know he's he
was fairly like elderly in this one but
he was later in the he was in the puppet
master movies which i said was the same
production company and then he was in
somebody pointed out he was in mr
sardonicus like back in the 60s that
dude looked like that dude from that
movie that we saw remember that movie
they had that dude in it
yeah see i feel like we say that kind of
[ __ ] all the time i feel like we kind of
say well because i never know like i do
we watch the movie and then sometimes
i'll be like hey that's that
[ __ ] from whatever yeah and then
later because usually before we record
these i'll at least do like some cursory
research on it so i can figure out but
sometimes i forget and like sometimes
you're like hey that actor and then like
i don't have anything prepared like to
know like who that is but some of the
people here were familiar now you got a
good memory though sometimes sometimes
you you know who they are from other
movies you remember names real well well
sometimes if if it's a movie that i've
seen a bunch of times um i can place it
you know what i mean put it into this
you stuff it
and particularly if it was something
that happened in the 80s like and it was
something that i saw a lot you know what
i mean yeah like you know the the other
day when we were watching the hatchet
movies and there was like a scene in
there with stephen jeffries i was like
hey it's it's evil ed from fright night
and for whatever reason i remembered
what the actor's name was as well uh
just probably because i've seen stuff
because i've seen fright night so many
times yeah but yeah so
so i really like that in
what i saw that [ __ ] on the delay of me
[ __ ] taking pookie off the stage i
was you go you guys hitting her with the
hat she's like oh no no i ain't going
anywhere
like i said she knows you're not gonna
do anything bad she knows i don't hurt
herself
it's like she resists she's she says now
[ __ ] you no i'll [ __ ] you
i mean the worst that you ever do is if
she's getting into real trouble like
he'll chuck a pillow at her or something
like that yeah she loses her [ __ ] if you
throw a pill
[Laughter]
she comes back though you miss me
well because any she likes any attention
yeah
um
yeah and she really likes to wrestle so
if you're not paying any attention to
her then she will absolutely just like
look at you right in the face and just
go over and go oh you don't want me to
like knock over all your [ __ ] i'm gonna
knock over all your [ __ ] like and then
she'll look at you like really defiantly
she thinks she's a human child she does
yes
yeah
yeah camp guy said dolls freak my wife
out she liked the telly savalas twilight
zone oh i remember that one that was
like with that creepy like uh this is
like i said this is a similar kind of
thing but it's more like a fairy tale
because it's almost kind of like
hansel and gretel type [ __ ] and like i
said you have the evil stepmother thing
uh the dad sucks too um he doesn't he
doesn't want the kid either so they're
just like putting up with this kid it's
like [ __ ] you kid and your [ __ ] kid
imagination like you you you suck and
all this other stuff other [ __ ] and so
when the little girl is like creeping
around she goes to get a glass of water
or something and she actually sees the
aha girl
getting dragged away by she doesn't know
their dolls at first she says she keeps
saying little people like she thinks
it's elves or something because she can
like hear them like creeping around in
the house
so she so she sees part of it and then
she goes and tells her dad and her dad's
like man [ __ ] off you don't know and uh
you know and he doesn't want to listen
to her so then she goes and tells ralph
like the nice guy and ralph doesn't
really believe her either but then like
he goes and there's she has like blood
all over her slippers and he's like oh
maybe there's something to this so he
actually does end up like believing her
and like helps her investigate and then
it comes there comes kind of a thing
where
her dad
like accuses ralph of killing
the people because then at that point
like the people start turning up dead
and everything but like i said they're
not
i guess they're still getting killed but
they're getting turned into dolls it's
what's happening and since the dolls
were still alive because there's a great
[ __ ] scene at the end where the dad
whose name is david um he [ __ ] up the
mr punch doll that the toy maker whose
name is gabriel gave to the little girl
and so gabriel's kind of like well i'm
just gonna turn you into the mr punch
doll and then you know what i mean so
he's so there's like a great
transformation of him like turning into
this little with his like [ __ ]
silk pajamas on do you remember those
[ __ ] pajamas from the 80s they were
like they were like bi-color it was kind
of like split in the middle and then it
was like gold and black and it was black
and gold yeah they were so he had like
these little looks like something emcee
hammer would wear
the empty hammer
hammer pajamas mc hammer jammies emcee
hammer wear that [ __ ] on stage though
crotch should be down to his [ __ ]
ankles how could he stand that i don't
know big old [ __ ] baggie on the top
and real narrow at the bottom dancing on
that [ __ ]
i cuz i feel like the 80s
yeah the 80s
well even even like women's jeans and
stuff like that in the 80s they had like
those big like butts so like the big
wide hips and then like the peg legs
and it's like it made everybody look
like a [ __ ] ice cream cone it's
[ __ ] terrible
i don't know i don't think i ever
yeah i don't think i ever met a single
person that those were flattering
i mean it just with the pleats on the
tops of the jeans and [ __ ] yeah why the
[ __ ] you wearing the chin yeah it made
everybody look like pregnant or like
they had a big huge fat ass and little
tiny ankles and they wore that [ __ ] like
it was normal
well that's all you could get yeah
that's all you could get that's like
some [ __ ] your mom would tell you to
wear
why aren't you wearing the pleats on the
tops no that's what was that was the
style because remember like guess what
it was like i guess it was like guest
jeans that was like kind of a big thing
when i was in uh junior high in high
school
and it's like you didn't even think
about it because that's what everyone
was wearing so it's like these just
these big like bunched it was forced on
you by the system when you went to the
[ __ ] mall that's where you shopped
back in the days every [ __ ] damn shop
had nothing but those it was forced on
you like communism it was like the it
was like it was like mal's little suit
capitalism said you can only buy this
so now everybody has to go around
looking like they have a big belly pooch
and big wide hips yeah and everybody has
to go around looking like a [ __ ]
triangle
man it was the worst yeah i guess they
didn't know any better but i thought it
looked [ __ ] terrible it did look
[ __ ] terrible and it was well and not
only that but a lot of them were [ __ ]
acid washed also which looked even worse
and then you'd see characters that in
movies that were kind of set more into
like the 1930s and the [ __ ] looked a lot
cooler
20s and 30s like they looked normal
yeah like you know what i mean like look
at indiana jones a lot of [ __ ] he's
wearing it just looks normal which is
weird yeah you could wear stuff from
like the 30s like yeah just like regular
clothes
nobody would probably better
it's just i kind of feel like 30 cent
badass jackets
badass leather jackets badass wool
[ __ ] coats and [ __ ] they looked they
looked good the weird thing about 30s is
that they were still all wearing hats
though
yeah you couldn't go anywhere without
any kind of hat i don't have a problem
with that there's some kind of [ __ ]
business hat or some kind of work hat
this is my business hat it was a hat
yeah that now fedora type [ __ ] hats
that [ __ ] businessman wore you know
yeah
some kind of some kind of [ __ ] hat
you know
it was a hat culture yeah couldn't show
your head
well yeah it was just kind of like yeah
well it was just hats on women little
round hats i even feel like maybe this
had started to phase out by that time
but i kind of feel like even my
grandmother remembered like if you were
going out to town like if you were going
to the store or something like that you
had to wear gloves gloves at a hat and
like women didn't wear pants ever like
if you wore pants that was like every
pot people thought some [ __ ] about you
yeah well we even said that when we were
talking about like amelia earhart and
like you know catherine hepburn i think
when she was younger um you know would
wear pants and it was like this big
[ __ ] deal you know what i mean which
is hilarious nowadays but
back then it was like a big deal
um yeah a lot of people don't know about
it back in the 20s and the 30s you had
girls [ __ ] being wild and [ __ ]
wearing pants and then cutting their
hair short and smoking and smoking
it was seen as almost transgender back
then it was yeah it was it was a it was
a big deal yeah just funny uh yeah tammy
said don't forget the shoulder pads oh
my god it's funny we were watching like
re-watching one of dan bell's videos
[ __ ] one of dan bell's videos and he
really likes to find like these old
uh infomercials and stuff like that and
kind of edit them in like with the 80s
and 80s with the footage and the one
that we were watching last night was
that exact thing there was one it was
like the contempo wrap if you guys
remember it was this it's basically like
a headband thing but it had like wire in
it because remember everybody had those
like poofy kind of like the chick does
in this movie like like madonna had like
that kind of poofy like headband kind of
look but you it was one where you didn't
have to like figure out complicated
knots or anything you could just like
have because it had like i guess it was
like floral wire inside so you had like
this big fluffy thing so they had that
and then he had one with
this it looked like a talk show or a
daily news show or something like that
where they were like saying and this
woman has like a big but like she's big
on the bottom and small on the top
they're saying she had a fat ass she
didn't though but and so it's like so
let's put some shoulder pads in there
we'll even it all out you know what i
mean which i think was kind of
that's what they were kind of trying to
do with shoulder pads and i remember
because i hated shoulder pads even back
in the 80s it was like look i don't need
any [ __ ] shoulder pads right and
you couldn't buy anything with shoulder
pads in there and sometimes you'd buy a
top and you're like well i can just cut
the shoulder pads out and then you'd get
in there and then be like sewn into a
thing where you couldn't cut them out
without making holes in it and it was
just like it was really depressing
i've been looking at fashion throughout
the [ __ ] eons
and to me i still think late 90s early
2000s looks the best
um i think it did i think the goth
fashion looked the best like the girls
from [ __ ] was it ginger snacks well i
mean they were wearing yeah i mean goth
fashion is alternative fashion is a
whole other thing because uh you know
and i thought [ __ ] girls with the
[ __ ] jinkos those ridiculous jinkos
and the [ __ ] little belly [ __ ]
shirts and [ __ ] [ __ ] those girls they
thought that looked good i thought the
hair was starting to get reasonable
you know what i mean
like we were talking about those girls
in that movie this is like the hair
remember yeah they saw a lot of that
that went on to maybe 2004 i think 2003
yeah
and it was just there wasn't anything
real extreme and there was a wide
variety of choices that's why i liked it
well like i said i kind of feel like
that's what's happening nowadays in the
same way that media has become more
democratized and become more niche i
feel like there's not really any one big
this is the mainstream fashion like
there was in the 80s right and early
1990s you had to be like this that was
it yeah like the early 90s mainstream
fashion like that horrible [ __ ] neon
yeah
that was like even worse than the 80s
but i kind of feel like you don't really
have that anymore you can kind of wear
whatever the vanilla ice era yeah
well it's funny yeah we were thinking
about vanilla ice too because we've been
re-watching
vanilla ice looked like a gumby
he did
well look like a white gumby
did you see was that a vanilla ice movie
cool as ice cold as ice cool
i'm not watching it without that come on
i'm not sitting through that [ __ ]
that movie was just like i might i was
like this the whole time from like the
cringe-worthiness
which i was like oh my god i'm gonna die
from cringe it was just like so like the
[ __ ] he was wearing was just so [ __ ]
obnoxious and like the way they were
talking was obnoxious and i'm like this
i was like this is why i hated the 90s
right here like there was some good [ __ ]
in the 90s too like not everything was
like that but there was so much of that
that i was just kind of like what the
[ __ ] are they even they're asking if i
have a vanilla ice wig no oh you should
know
that you should get one yeah you should
get one yeah that's somebody who's
asking is tom balding dude i'm [ __ ]
bald somebody
and i am balding man i got all the
[ __ ] hair in the world i gotta pick a
pile right over there i put it on for
every kind of character i want a big
pile of got a big pile of [ __ ] hair
over there [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
dreadlocks or no dreadlocks i actually
quite like dreadlocks it depends on the
person though just kind of like
just kind of like any hair put my elvis
wig on i mean we have a
we have a friend named uh named shauna
who has like really really cool
dreadlocks and she's had them like
forever she's like a hair she you know
did hair and stuff like that too so you
can put my oh i'm gonna put my that's
what i was gonna say i just kind of feel
like fur since we're kind of talking
about dolls and we're talking about the
80s
so
dolls 80s amadeus i'm gonna put my
authentic white boy wig on there you go
my caucasian [ __ ] credentials go up
quite a bit i'm ready to pass some laws
up in this place
ready to pass some laws that's right
tom's wigging out that's right
yeah so
okay so i will say that this movie i
don't know
if i'd go quite as far as to say it's
like a lost classic or anything
but
because it's like a lot different than
reanimator from beyond
it has like the same tone but it's
almost i almost want to say it's like a
kids horror movie you know in the same
way that like monster squad or
something like that is where there's
still like scary [ __ ] in it and there's
still some gore in it
but
you could let a kid watch it and they
wouldn't be too traumatized yeah you
know what i'm saying
what you're talking about vanilla eyes
if we'd seen the vanilla ice skate with
jim carrey i think i did actually that
dude will never i don't know what
vanilla ice's real name was i heard it
one time [ __ ] but i don't remember
either that dude will never live that
[ __ ] down well that's what you get for
coming out of the gate with that
[ __ ] that he had going on
he was a flash in the pan he made a lot
of money very quickly i think they
mostly made money off of him i don't
think he kept most of that because he's
not rich
yeah well it did doesn't need anything
working as a carpenter no any a
carpenter or something because i feel
like he had a reality show trying to
come back make comebacks well he was on
like kind of the you know how for a long
time i don't know if they still have
these because i don't really watch tv
but they had all those kind of like
reality shows with like these has been
yeah like let's put a bunch of has been
celebrities like in one house together
like the real world except with washed
up celebrities yeah so i feel like he
might have been on one of those yeah
robert van winkles i mean robert van
winkle that's his name that's his name
well so like rip van winkle yeah
yeah that's not his name right now i had
a chain
no robert van winkle i said oh like rip
family yeah
who is robert van winkle vanilla ice
that's his real name yeah you're not
[ __ ] with me
no that sounds like a joke
louis says suge knight took all his
money yeah maybe yeah well maybe he just
took his money away from him because
he's like boy we can't give you anybody
look at how you're [ __ ] dressing i no
i think
yeah
i'm not going to give you money you're
just going to buy that [ __ ] with it
i have a feeling that that was his job
to be vanilla ice they put him up to
that and that was all that was a
creation of some company
i don't think that that's yeah it did it
definitely did seem to like let's hit
all the like early 90s tropes all the
time
and i don't think that was his creation
i think he was kind of an actor singer
performer vanilla icington
but yeah yeah
because that can that that that did that
in no way did he have a legitimate
feel like he was a real person that that
was not
that was not a real musician or a
[ __ ] rap star that was an artificial
construct and yeah and i feel like that
becomes abundantly clear if you watch
the movie that movie it is abundantly
like don't watch it without the rift
tracks because it's
insufferable yeah but dude could be like
that
i hope not no he was instructed to be
that way and that was a role he was
playing good lord that could not have
been and and it feels like it wasn't his
idea it feels to me like some company
put him up to do that
to make money and i have a feeling that
a lot of the black artists are like that
too
that they're more of a cr artificial
creation to a certain extent well i mean
if you want to make money you have to
like go down certain channels that right
you know i just think they think we'll
do it with a white guy kind of like
elvis or something like that you know
let's bring it to the masses
that [ __ ]
yeah it worked for what a few months
well no i think it was longer than that
well because i i thought about them we
were thinking about them last night
because like i said we've been
rewatching uh the toys that made us
and we were watching the teenage mutant
ninja turtles episode and remember he
did that the theme song for the first
movie i want to say go ninja go ninja
yeah you did that ridiculous
that was the first teenage mutant ninja
turtles see i don't remember it it just
goes to show you how damaging
how damaging the old media was when it
was
totally corporate controlled it was only
a couple companies controlling
television and radio there was no way
to get out
from
from around it i mean it was like a
cannon pointed at you they shot into you
whatever they
invested in and they made that product
and shot it out of there
like it was any like it was drano
or palmolive or any other [ __ ]
products that they made
and you throw enough [ __ ] against the
wall it'll stick
if you repeat it as enough times people
will i guess get addicted to it for a
while
either that or they're or they'll blow
their own head off away from it
which is which is what camp i'm in it
just let's you just i remember feeling
that at the time
that anything that was popular was
totally artificially generated that
there was nothing
nothing organic organic about it yeah
you know like
the way the beetles were or something
that was kind of organic no no totally
totally artificial
they make a bunch of money on it out of
a artificial construct and then when it
stops stops making money they replace it
with another product just like making
those damn
cartoons and toys and [ __ ] is that exact
same [ __ ] method
and he just got screwed because he got
pigeonholed into ice ice baby [ __ ]
mode there was no way he could get out
from around that it destroyed his career
he couldn't do anything else
after that yeah
because he could probably be an okay
actor or a singer maybe
doing other things but
people
they put him into that first and that
was it
i mean if you're like
well not necessarily because you you
kind of have like people like um you
know mark wahlberg who was in was he and
new kids on the block or was he in the
other city there was a couple of
wahlbergs but um i think they own a
burger franchise now which is actually
quite successful but anyway yeah
it's a little more organic though but
well the thing about the whole new kids
on the block and all that kind of [ __ ]
was that that was maybe that was donnie
wahlberg so i feel like okay so mark
wahlberg was the brother of donnie
wahlberg who's in new kids on the block
but then mark wahlberg had marky mark in
the funky bunch yeah so other like white
boy rappers but he actually parlayed so
i guess he was like actually talented
and he actually was able to
you know go into acting and then he was
actually became a quite successful actor
yeah will smith was like that he was
another artificial construct and so was
uh l cool j that's they're in that same
thing
yeah they had a lot of corporate backing
from very beginning from the very
beginning but they were both talented
and likable for some reason
ice was not likable
he could not or he couldn't do other
things or he couldn't do other maybe he
wasn't versatile i think he could
because i think he was trying to do
metal and [ __ ] but you already [ __ ] up
your career because you're associated
with with rap maybe well maybe if he
hadn't made that movie maybe he could
have got away with it a little bit maybe
cause that movie like i said oh my god i
couldn't believe i think mark wahlberg
[ __ ] um actually was able to continue
and get bigger because because he would
do controversial roles and he would get
in trouble for real yeah punch people
out and [ __ ] which that adds to your
street cred
mr roboto says jenny were you and new
kids on the block fan absolutely not we
hate all that [ __ ] honestly i mean by
the time that came along
that was like i was too old for that
um when when i was a kid in the 80s i
was into duran duran yeah you know what
i mean new kids on the block that was
like 90s i was already at a high school
by then
um you know what i mean so that was like
way too old for me we are sidetracked
like a [ __ ] is uh uh
we're finished with dolls right
yeah i'm just saying it's a if if you
like stuart gordon and you haven't seen
this one don't be expecting the same
thing as like a reanimator from beyond
because it's not like as wacky or gory
or anything as that but it's almost kind
of like um grandpa's hammer i think said
something because i was saying it was
more like a kid-oriented sort of and he
said like the gate i was like yeah it's
the it's kind of like the gate but it's
it's almost kind of like a fairy
tale-ish yeah it's a fairy tale story is
essentially what it's a decent movie i
much prefer from beyond to react well
yeah i do too
but i mean and the acting in this is a
little bit like some of the people are
good and some of them are not so good
um
but i will say i think the strength of
it i really liked like the little girl
character was cool like the the ralph
guy like the kind of lovable schlubby
guy was cool the um the old couple was
cool
and it was just kind of like um and the
doll effects i think are the best or
like the highlight of the movie i think
because i think like all because there's
like a [ __ ] ton of different dolls and
like the way they do the puppets and the
way they do transformation and the way
they move around like the stop motion is
actually really really good for
a movie of this time and of this budget
so like i said it's on shutter it might
also be on to be
uh so you know if you don't have shutter
but you should get shutter because
shutter is off it's cheap and it's got
good [ __ ] on it i yeah i mean i only pay
i think it's
56.99 for a year
yeah you know what i mean and sometimes
they give you like free t-shirts and
[ __ ] too if you're just like five five
something a month it's like less than
five dollars a month if you pay yearly
because i think if you pay month to
month i think it's 4.99 or 5.99 a month
or something like that so it's still
like nothing
um and they always have good [ __ ] on
there like i said they have new [ __ ] and
old [ __ ] and everything um
it's like
yeah comparable to puppet master it's
yeah it's about the same thing i haven't
seen the first puppet mastering along i
know they made like 40 bajillion pop-up
master movies i remember liking those as
well this one it seems like a slightly
different vibe but it's kind of in the
same ballpark and i would when did
child's play come out child's play came
out after this right i don't know 88 i
want to say the first child's play was
88 so it might have been like a year
after this one
because this was released in 87 but they
actually made it like i said before they
made uh i don't remember child's play i
remember the name but i don't remember
you know chucky chucky okay yeah that's
right yeah one with chucky no with
chucky
yeah no i would probably put child's
play above this
well yeah child's play is a classic
classic um but you know put this one up
there with maybe like a house
yeah
similar to house which is the one that
we're doing we did this today yeah well
we recorded it it'll be up right it'll
be up friday or thursday if you're a
patron you can see it
uh yeah mike barrett says this is my
favorite doll horror film ahead of the
chucky films interesting yeah like i
kind of like like i said i liked the
the witchy like very taily kind of vibe
that it had
and like i said it had a little bit of
at the beginning it was almost kind of
like reminded me of rocky horror picture
show a little bit
i don't know i think it's kind of funny
the the one that had the dolls that was
better than this was the one that uh
[ __ ] what was the one
what was the name of that one that had
the [ __ ] dude who was using his
psychic powers tourist tourist trip
actually somebody somebody brought that
up earlier they said they wondered if
the poster had been done by the same
person because the toaster looked kind
of similar i don't really know i think
there's trap is really i think i said
toaster instead of poster yeah um yeah
we did a review on that a while back i
actually i wouldn't mind revisiting that
i love tourist straps
darker
more twisted
yeah yeah creepier i think what happened
with this one was that charles band i
think him or his designer because like i
said he had that production company it
was kind of the thing where you know
like you saw in the edward movie where
it's kind of like hey i got a poster
with a title and this is what the poster
looks like so make a movie about that
um i think that's what happened with
this one like it's like look we made
this poster it's called dolls it's like
creepy like this now make a movie that
goes along with this poster so i think
that might have been what happens uh
with this situation just like those kids
cartoons
are actually made after they make the
toys they make the toys first well like
i said if you if you have netflix watch
the toys that made us because
i know people like talk about like the
80s and you know they fondly remember
like all the toys and stuff like you
know teenage mutant ninja turtles and
he-man and everything but
you know you can complain all you want
about oh corporate this and that and the
other but that's exactly what they were
doing the whole reason that they did the
cartoons was to sell the toys toys i
mean they started out with the toys and
then they're like well the kids need a
story or they won't buy these
so make a cartoon they pull a toy out of
the ass
and then they pull the story about the
toy out of the ass
and they pull the [ __ ] movie about
the story out of the house it's all
pulled out of the hat
but but the damn toy was made first it
didn't even have a name
they're like how do we make sense all
these and then well this one is that and
this one then that that's that's how
that's just done well that's kind of
we're just trying to sell that damn toy
we were re-watching the transformers
ones and those were essentially they
just took a bunch of japanese toys
renamed and renamed them and like gave
them backstories and stuff because they
didn't really have that like on the
japanese market they were just like
transforming robots because that was
like a big trend in japan at the time so
it's just kind of like yeah but we want
like a whole story about these so they
give it to like this one poor dude in an
office and it's like hey come up with 26
names for these robots and like give
them a backstory and like how it all
fits together yeah he's using some dude
that they like he's not even a [ __ ]
really like an experienced writer they
just know he's creative here make up no
names for all these and stories okay
well then yeah over the weekend yeah
yeah he said he did it over the weekend
he came up with like the main 26 like
transformers
it's just like that's like super funny
that's just it's funny i mean but it's
you know that's just how that's how
creative [ __ ] works you know it's like
yeah it's cynical
yeah you know everybody's just trying to
make money but
in in a way it's like even though he-man
i think is probably like the main thing
of that because he-man wasn't anything
and they just they just had all these
toys and they're like well we need to
come up with a new toy line and then
they're like okay well no one's gonna
buy this if there isn't a cartoon so
then we have to make the cartoon they
have to like pay an animation studio to
make it so we can sell more toys that's
what they're you know trying to do
but
like i said you can say that cynical but
the kids that bought the toys and played
with them i mean they probably had a
good time playing with the toys and it's
like a lot of people collect them and
stuff so you know what i think is
funniest about the he-man story and i'm
way off topic we me and you were way off
topic but i think one of the funniest
things is that one of the reasons why
he-man was created is it was just an
excuse
one of the excu
one of the reasons was it was a way of
selling a [ __ ]
lame-ass [ __ ]
tiger they had a tiger a cast tiger
and
they had to sell that
it was something they had made years
before they just had it had it sitting
around let's sell this thing yeah and
they go oh well you know paint it green
put stripes on it put a saddle on that
thing
just put him on the saddle that's weird
when you think about it yeah that part
of the contributing thing that caused
he-man to be made and all those toys was
to sell that [ __ ] stupid-ass tiger
well in the inventory it worked yeah so
you know
remember that tiger [ __ ] didn't even
move
it was just a solid [ __ ] hollow tiger
but it was just it would couldn't move
yeah my brother like the worst [ __ ]
toy possible i thought its legs moved or
at least back and forth i don't think it
did at all i can't remember oh it's been
a long time justin had one [ __ ]
steve's little brother had it and me and
me and steve were looking at it because
look at this [ __ ] we were amazed of the
[ __ ] they would sell kids
you know we were teenagers at the time
look at this amazing look at this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
yeah mr roboto says what's with charles
bandon puppets yeah i didn't realize
because charles band his production
company not only did this movie
uh and the puppet master movies but
there was like a bunch of other ones too
like was like demonic toys didn't he
also do demonic toys which was a similar
kind of [ __ ] so he's really and i think
there was like a handful more than that
that i can't remember at the moment so i
kind of feel like
his thing is he is really into
little thing like little toys little
dolls little things like that attacking
people he's like super
into that um vibe and it seems like most
of the movies he wants to make or comes
up with he's like i have an idea let's
have this little bitty thing like you
know a little doll or a little um teddy
bear or something like that that kills
people yeah the end
that's kind of like
grampus goes justin his poor mom yeah
his [ __ ] mom he redrove his mom
justin destroyed that whole [ __ ]
house
that was the weirdest thing never seen a
[ __ ] little kid destroy a goddamn
house pulled all the [ __ ] covered
doors off the damn house
off the kitchen cabinets over time just
[ __ ] had just piles of [ __ ] toys
everywhere looking that kid was insane i
think i'd be returning that child
yeah here here take that one what's
funny is that you let me have another i
want to exchange it he grew up he grew
up to be normal but that that kid was
just [ __ ]
a nut absolutely insane
i knew some kids like that like i said
my my parents ran daycares off and on um
and we had some kids like that but they
most of them grew up okay yeah he muslim
girl he literally [ __ ]
reduced that house to just a worthless
[ __ ]
house
can you imagine if you had a kid like
that oh my god he scribbled on every
[ __ ] wall put holes in the wall and
he was like
eight seven eight nine
old enough yeah all of them don't bash
holes in the wall
[ __ ] uh tear everything out of the
covers and just throw it on the ground
walk away from it just [ __ ] kid was
nuts man i never seen anything like it
maybe he needed an exorcism he's like he
was yeah
graduates could explain it he's been
over that house
we had we had a kid my mom babies had a
kid that was kind of like that yeah
there's just some kids little boys
mostly yeah well i've seen a
every now and then you see a little girl
like that but mostly it's little boys
and they're just their whole thing and a
lot of it is not even malicious they
just like want to destroy [ __ ] grandpa
said something what do you say i can't
read a prayer i remember when she sent
him to summer camp for juvenile
delinquents yeah
he was he ended up okay though but man
please let him stop like trashing my
house i'd go over to see [ __ ] steve
and steven be sitting there man he's
just totally [ __ ] just sick of the
[ __ ] he'd be [ __ ] scowled on his face
he couldn't stand his little brother
tearing everything up he had to lock
everything and then he'd try to
to keep him out of it but then he'd pull
the panelings off the [ __ ] walls and
[ __ ] slip in between so he could get
in and out of a room and without having
to [ __ ] break the lock on the door
yeah that's the kind of kid it was he
was it was like living with a chimpanzee
yeah oh my god yeah he was [ __ ] nuts
camp guy said she would let him stay
past the pickup day yeah just like
forget to like pick him up
maybe someone else will take him his dad
was like [ __ ] this he'll go he'll go
live in the wild like some of the feral
children like this show we did a couple
weeks his dad [ __ ] said [ __ ] this and
ran off and [ __ ] like immediately
hooked up with like a 22 year old
in that situation though you probably
can't believe yeah i remember me and
[ __ ] steve are sitting there he shows
up [ __ ] picking up the last of his
[ __ ] jumps in his [ __ ] current
convertible with with his new girlfriend
and waves goodbye he's with us 22 23
year old blonde and me and [ __ ] steve
are sitting there going that
[ __ ] is living the life
see you bro see it he's like yeah you
guys haven't given us [ __ ] takes off
good luck with all that good luck with
that
[ __ ] yeah greg was young though it's
funny you know looking back on it we saw
him as an old man greg was probably like
30 31 32. well when you're a kid when
you're a kid or he looks old he's like
[ __ ] this
yeah
well like i said if i was the mom i
probably would have left the kid there
too and be like yeah i'm going to go
live in another house you know he ran
right over that mom jesus christ
yeah see this every day i'm just glad
yeah
[Laughter]
every time i hear a story like that i'm
like whew dodged a bullet there that's
funny but
yeah
so uh all right are we are we done we've
been almost an hour i can't believe it
and we mostly mostly talked about the
movie yeah but yeah it's on shutter
check it out they like [ __ ] they got
free entertainment they got yeah well
you know it's look at your [ __ ] hair
you're killing me yeah i'm [ __ ] being
white
[Laughter]
like on the money what's that i'm being
like that dude off the [ __ ] money
like off the [ __ ] oatmeal [ __ ] box
oh yeah i don't need to yeah like they
do not [ __ ] opioids sorry i just had
like i saw i had a graphic design moment
where i was just kind of like oh i could
take a picture of you and then i could
make like the quakeroo
[Laughter]
i could make the quaker oats box but
with you on it yeah oh my god that'd be
super funny all right so uh it's tuesday
today which means that tomorrow night at
5 p.m eastern standard time is our side
track show
like this isn't a sidetrack show but you
know what i mean our all side tracks
show that's what we should probably
start calling it so yeah we do have
booze right we don't have to go get
anybody no we're good okay we still got
some booze we have we haven't drunk
since friday yeah that's fine i don't
think you try to lose some weight man i
think i had one on saturday's got a lot
of calories in it it does yeah but yeah
so uh come on by tomorrow
evening afternoon whatever you want to
call it and uh we'll have some drinks
and talk about some [ __ ] i don't
know we'll talk about toys some more i
don't know what we're going to talk
about we'll find out but yeah so thanks
everybody for dropping by and have a
good rest of your day and all that we'll
see you guys tomorrow